the effect it's had on the people of
Israel the people of UAE uh the the
optimism and opportunity uh is brought
to the Middle East uh none of that has
been has been covered uh at all and I
think it's all because of uh because it
came from from from us from the Trump
Administration yeah but that's that's no
bloody excuse here that's no excuse
like this is
political as far as I'm concerned and I
think as far as anybody reasonable would
be concerned and it's important to give
the devil his due and that's the case
even if the devil happens to be Trump
and his damned minions and the facts
seem to me to be clear on the ground
that this represents a significant and
very unexpected move forward on the
Peace front in the Middle East and
that's been a problem that has
threatened all of us for
for 70 years for longer than that on all
sorts of fronts
[Music]
hello everyone it's my great pleasure
and privilege to have with me today
Ambassador David Friedman
as the United States ambassador to
Israel from March 2017 until January
Ambassador Friedman successfully guided
unprecedented diplomatic advancements in
the U.S Israel relationship including
moving the United States Embassy to
Jerusalem a move that was promised by
many previous administrations but never
occurred and recognizing Israeli
sovereignty over the Golan Heights
he is also among a very small group of
American officials signally responsible
for the Abraham Accords
comprehensive peace and normalization
agreements between Israel and the United
Arab Emirates Bahrain Sudan and Morocco
for which he was nominated for the Nobel
Peace Prize in 2021
Ambassador Friedman
was recognized in each of the past five
years by the Jerusalem Post as one of
the 50 most influential Jews in the
world coming in first in 2020
he also was named one of the 20 most
impactful persons of the past decade by
the Jewish telegraphic agency
Ambassador Friedman was honored by
President Trump
with a rare National Security medal in
September 2020 and by the U.S Joint
Chiefs of Staff with the meritorious
civilian service medal in April 2019. he
has received numerous other honors
recognitions and awards including
honorary doctorates from Yeshiva
University in New York and Ariel
University in the Chevron
on February 8 20 22nd Harper Collins
published Ambassador Friedman's memoir
sledgehammer how breaking with the past
brought peace to the Middle East
in his first week Sledgehammer broke
sales records for a book on the state of
Israel
Ambassador Friedman is also the founder
of the Friedman Center for peace through
strength which works to build upon the
ambassador's achievements in
strengthening the U.S Israel
relationship
welcome Ambassador Friedman David uh
it's a pleasure to talk to you I'm very
pleased that you're willing to share
what you've done with me and my audience
and
um
welcome to the discussion
thank you Jordan it's an honor to be on
your show
so let's start let's Jump Right In uh
let's start with an overview of the
Abraham Accords and
people are I'm sure that my ignorance is
shared by many people
um we can start right from the beginning
what did you do and why and what does it
mean
well the Abraham Accords is a series of
agreements between Israel
four Muslim countries if you had Kosovo
in Europe it's actually five Muslim
countries
and uh you know people have heard for
years for decades about the arab-israeli
conflict the most intractable if you
will of all the conflicts and uh you
know there was some progress made in the
1970s with Egypt and then in 1994 with
Jordan and and that was it 25 years and
there was no progress and you had the
the Arab League consisting of about 22
countries that reflexively would oppose
Israel not just at the United Nations
but in every diplomatic attempt made by
uh the United States so the United
States accepted this conventional wisdom
that had been around for 50 years that
until Israel made progress with the
Palestinians there could be no progress
among any other of the Arab Nations
which was uh in many respects
counter-attuitive we proved it to be
flat out wrong
and as a result the uh the the the
Middle East remained the very dangerous
place with with really no opportunities
for any advancement that was standing
the fact they were there were more than
20 Arab countries all with different
issues different populations
um different concerns we knew that
Israel and some of these countries
already had covert contacts we knew that
most of these countries didn't hate
Israel some of them didn't even know why
they didn't like Israel some of them you
know just reflexively acted against
Israel but you couldn't do anything
because of this conventional wisdom uh
John Kerry was the biggest cheerleader
for this point of view that until Israel
makes peace with the Palestinians you
you can't move forward and
um you know when we came into office in
2017 we were given a mandate from
president Trump to try to bring some
greater modicum of peace to the Middle
East and
um and and what we recognized was that
virtually everything that was in The
Playbook of the state department for the
past 50 years which was just wrong it
was just wrong it was stale it was it
had done nothing but increased the
misery of of the peoples living in the
region and we started to take a
different attack and you know there's
lots of pieces to that I'm happy to go
through them as as you'd like me to but
we basically just changed all the rules
of the gaming okay so what accounts for
this remarkable intransigence on this
front lasting 50 years
the evidence for the validity of your
Viewpoint is that when you challenge
this presumption and you said the
central presumption was there was no
movement possible on the arab-israeli
front or let's say on the Muslim Israeli
front maybe to broaden it to some degree
if that's not appropriate there was no
progress possible on that without
movement
in relationship to peace with the
Palestinians and so that was accepted
dogma and it and it it put things into
stasis for five decades now you pointed
out that the countries that that are uh
relevant to such an agreement are
diverse and share a very diverse range
of opinions let's say towards Israel and
so why was this accepted Dogma
on the state Department's part and why
was that accepted in some sense without
question by presidents other than Trump
until recently I mean this is the
biggest peace issue in the world it has
been since I've been alive I would say
with the possible exception of
the the constant clamoring on the Cold
War front so how do you account for this
well I found that I found it disturbing
in uh at times amusing I you know I
entered government uh from the outside
uh I had briefings early on when I was
confirmed as Ambassador with people in
the state department
and
um to them the entire Arab Israeli
conflict was simply boiled down to
Israel and the Palestinians now
first of all that's you know that that
was just the accepted dog but I
challenged it I challenged it on
numerous occasions and they said look
you know it's it's a great question
you're wasting your time you're
completely wasting your time the
Palestinians are the issue if you solve
the Palestinian issue you can unlock the
rest of the Arab world the rest of the
Muslim world as you say if you can't
solve the uh Palestinian issue nobody
else will even will even talk to you now
just to put that into into a bigger
context
when you say the Palestinian issue okay
you're talking about Israel not just
um making uh peace with the Palestinian
Authority which in and of itself is is a
corrupt
um uh organization whose leader as
people like to say is in the 17th year
of his four-year term you know he was
elected for four years he hasn't had
elections since he stayed on another 13
years with no Democratic mandate he runs
a corrupt
government
he respects no human rights the justice
system is is non-existence the financial
transparency is non-existent uh there is
extraordinary subjugation of women uh
homosexuality is a is a crime punishable
by death I mean this and those are the
those are the good guys right then you
have Hamas which is uh which which
operates in the West Bank but primary
early controls the Gaza Strip take all
that and and they're extraordinarily
violent and they don't even accept the
notion that uh that one Jew should live
anywhere between the Mediterranean Sea
and the Jordan River so there's the
these are the people these are the
organizations that the state department
says until you get them on board
all right you can't move any further
within the region and and there's
there's really no way to get them on
board I mean there really isn't anyway
okay so there's so there's two issues
that work there from what I understand
then the first is
what appears to me to be an
oversimplified rationalization for
failure to move forward which would be
the acceptance of a low resolution
ideology that you can boil down all the
complexities of the Arab slash Muslim
slash Palestinian relationship to the
issue of
of Palestine and that because that's
intractable there's no point wasting
effort on the attempt to to take a more
differentiated approach to Bringing
peace to the Middle East combined with
and this is a mystery that we could also
delve into the fact that there seems to
be a reflexive identification for many
on the west with the Palestinians on the
side of this conflict and it seems to me
that's fueled by this equally Global and
vague reductive notion that the
Palestinians are oppressed and oppressed
people are always virtuous and since
oppressed people are virtuous the
Israelis must be oppressors and wrong
despite whatever sins let's say the
Palestinian leadership manifests which
are justifiable in any case because of
the fact that they're oppressed and
couldn't possibly know better
is that too cynical
it no no it's it's not the it's it's not
even cynical enough I mean you could you
could take it another step which is
um the the Palestinians apart from uh
apart from the the your point about well
you know they must be right if they're
weak you know which is of course
um uh one does not flow from the other
but you know the Palestinian leadership
the Palestinian Authority which is again
you know as as people say the least
dirty shirt in the closet the
Palestinian Authority uh spends hundreds
of million dollars from its budget that
could otherwise be used to build you
know a hospital or a school they use
that money to reward and incentivize
terrorists to kill Jews okay and the
United States
um funds the Palestinian Authority we
didn't under Trump we cut that all out
but you know Biden has recently uh
resumed all that funding so just to put
this in perspective the United States of
America the taxpayers of the United
States are paying the Palestinian
Authority to incentivize their people to
kill Jews I mean it's that's not too
broad a statement so okay so okay well I
don't often get accused of not being
cynical enough but I do appreciate that
correction so let's re let's return to
the Palestinian issue later because we
don't want to get sidelined entirely by
that as the whole world has been
sidelined for five decades let's talk
about the UAE Bahrain Sudan and Morocco
and you said Kosovo and so these
countries for some reason were willing
to move Beyond let's say this state
department dicta and work with you to
improve relations with Israel and to
improve the possibility of Peace in the
Middle East and so why were they willing
to do that and why them in particular
so let me Focus I'll I'll share with you
a conversation I had with uh because I
think it's the most telling with um
who is the foreign minister of the
United Arab Emirates and I sat with him
you know uh this past summer after the
Abraham Accords were already you know
out for for more than a year
and uh and I said to him
um
is this just about Israel having common
enemies with you know Iran and Bahrain
is just about the fact that everybody
doesn't like and is threatened by Iran
um or or is there more to this you know
what what in your mind got us started
and what he said to me and he said
something which I thought was very
profound although probably the Russian
Ukraine war maybe the exception that
proves that rule but what he said to me
is you know
in the uh in in the 21st century the
real conflicts in the world are not
really between nations anymore they're
really between ideologies and primarily
and primarily they're between extremists
and moderates and we in the UAE were
fighting that battle and in the United
States you're fighting that battle and
in Israel you're fighting that battle
you know you have roughly you know 80
percent of the populations are
um you know center right center left you
know in the middle uh in the past
they've always been able to find common
ground but now you know you've got 10
people crazy on the left 10 crazy on the
right uh you know uh on on you know uh
extremists you know willing to resort to
violence to achieve their means
um and
that's the fight that we have to win and
Israel and UAE and America and Bahrain
and you know in Morocco we're all on the
same side of that fight our interests
are completely aligned and I thought you
know I mean that look that's after the
fact but that's as good as an
explanation as I've heard from anybody
as to why the Abraham Accords came
together but
this is very important just because you
know there are reasons for people to
align you have to create the right
environment to do that you have to
create the political opportunity for it
to happen you have to create the kind of
the United States has to create you know
the coverage
um you know for for these countries to
move out of their comfort zone and so it
was a long process and and and if I can
it began in May of 2017 I can share with
you what I think was the was the first
step and one of the most important if I
could share that with you now
please do please do so you know the very
first trip that President Trump took to
the Mideast was in I'm sorry the very
very first trip president Trump took uh
on foreign soil was to the Mideast
and he went to three places first place
he went was to Riyadh in Saudi Arabia
where he he assembled 50 Muslim nations
and he said two things to them and and
the tape is extraordinary they were at
wrapped attention and he said two things
which I don't think any president has
ever said before the first thing he said
was
um radical Islamic terrorism is your
problem in the first instance I don't I
don't want to have to deal with it on my
side of the Atlantic don't make me deal
with radical Islamic Islamic terrorism
you solve the problem it's coming from
here and if you do you will find the
United States to be an extraordinarily
good friend okay that was the first
thing you said and a lot of people
listen and a lot of people acted on the
second thing he said is for those of you
still wasting your time thinking that
Israel is going to be wiped off the map
or they're not going to exist you're
wasting your time forget about it it's
never going to happen Okay Israel you
should be seeking to
um to emulate you know Israel as an
economy as a power as a democracy you
know this is this is a solution this is
a solution in the Middle East it's not a
problem and those of you who still think
it's a problem and think somehow you're
gonna you're gonna shortchange Israel or
get it to go away or push it into the
sea it's a pipe dream you're wasting
your time it'll never happen and it's
inconsistent with the relationship with
the United States you said those two
things and and and let me tell you you
know
um you know at the time
we couldn't tell you how how far that
would go but now looking back from uh
from in hindsight boy was that an
important speech and he doesn't get any
of the credit he deserves for it but boy
was that important the next thing he
does because he flies
um directly to Tel Aviv now they told
him you know Mr President we have to
stop at Amman why because uh you can't
fly from Riyadh to Tel Aviv the Saudis
won't let and and the President says I
just spent you know two days with the
King he's making me
stop in Amman he's making me kind of go
out of my way just for some symbolic
gesture tell them I want to fly straight
from Riyadh to Tel Aviv
and um and of course when he made that
request it was granted and this was the
first flight ever from Riyadh to Tel
Aviv you know Biden's making a big deal
now that he's flying straight to Saudi
Arabia from Tel Aviv the president of
the United States under Trump did it
five years ago okay so he then he comes
to he comes to uh Israel where does he
go
he does something no president has ever
done before he goes to the Western Wall
he's the only sitting president to go to
the Western Wall why is that important
because you know presidents used to like
to come to Israel and go to yadav Hashem
which is the Holocaust Memorial is an
extraordinary place it's one of the most
stirring places on Earth
but Yad vashem is not the state of
Israel yadav Hashem is not the DNA of
the state of Israel the DNA of the state
of Israel
is the Western Wall it's the Temple
Mount this is what connects the Jewish
people to their 4 000 year old history
you know at the Western Wall you see
Mount Moriah where uh where Abraham
bound Isaac you have the two temples
this is the place where Jews have prayed
for 2000 years to be returned well Trump
went there again the only sitting
president ever to visit the Western Wall
Biden wouldn't go I mean he was too
timid you know he reverted to that you
know that kind of stale you know sense
of even-handedness uh he wouldn't go
so the president goes to the to the
Western Wall and he gave an incredible
speech in Israel again uh recognizing
not just that the Jewish people have
suffered which of course Jews have
suffered throughout history
but but they did more than suffer they
they built something they restored uh
their their their people to the land of
Israel fulfilling not Vengeance for the
Holocaust but fulfilling a 2 000 year
old dream unfulfilled dream of the
Jewish people and then last but not
least he went to the Vatican okay and he
met with the Pope and he Incorporated
you know the Christian theology uh into
um into his overall uh message so this
was the seeds that were planted that
eventually got us to the Abraham of
course lots of steps then along the way
we'll get back to more with Ambassador
David Friedman in just a second first
we'd like to tell you about Birch gold
the Consumer Price Index has reached yet
another 40-year high and the latest GDP
numbers confirmed that the United States
is in a recession now is not the time to
have all your money in the stock market
or tied to the US dollar take action to
protect your savings from a highly
turbulent economy Now by diversifying at
least some of your Investment Portfolio
into gold and silver from Birch gold
group text Jordan to 999 9898 and Birch
gold will send you a free information
kit on how to transition an IRA or
eligible 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals Birch gold will even help you
hold gold in a tax sheltered account for
decades investors have relied on gold
and silver as a hedge against inflation
now you can too with an A plus rating
with a Better Business Bureau countless
5 Star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers secure your future
with gold from Birch gold now text
Jordan to 989-898 and get real help from
Birch gold today again text Jordan to
989898 to claim your free no obligation
information kit on how to protect your
hard-earned savings with gold
okay so you said that Trump went to
riyadhi he brought 50 Muslim nations
together and he made two very blunt
Decker declarations which was
to control terrorism to place that back
in some sense in the domain of the
responsibility of the Muslim countries
and that is in accordance with the
discussion that you described with uh
the leaders from the UAE that the people
civilized people of the world that say
are suffering from the same problem
which is how do you control a minority
of extremists and we can get back to
that and then Trump also said
forthrightly two other things that the
that there's that the Americans are
going to throw their weight behind
Israel permanently and so any dream of
eradicating Israel's estate uh is a pipe
dream unless the consequences are are
unless you're willing to face the
consequences let's say and that also
that Israel should be regarded as a
state to emulate given its Democratic
structure and its thriving economy and
its ability let's say to regenerate the
desert and all of that and that it could
be viewed as a partner to learn from and
appreciate rather than as an enemy and
then the emphasis on the necessity for
The Unbroken flight the visit to the
Western Wall and the visit to the
Vatican and so what why in the world was
Trump able to do that why was he willing
to do that and what made him let's say
simultaneously a friend of the Jews and
Israel but also someone that the Arabs
and the Muslims more broadly were
willing to deal with
who is willing to do it because
um you know you know he first of all he
assembled um a group of people that that
he respected and that I think you know
we're all moving this direction
primarily I would say Jared Kushner and
me two two guys no government experience
but people that he had great respect for
uh we we explained to him that
um
this this conflict was was going nowhere
and unless he you know radically uh
realigned America's priorities uh you
know he would finish his term in office
the same way everybody else did and and
we had these discussions and and I think
look he
um he is the right president for the
Middle East because he is he is strong
he is fearless I mean he he look he he
he worked that uh you know those actions
were manifest throughout his four years
including you know the the decision to
um
to assassinate qasim suleimani which you
know was
um an extraordinary message he sent to
the Iranians but the president is very
strong he's a strong leader and in the
Middle East you know we have a saying
you know in the Middle East you're
either strong or you're dead you know
and um everybody everybody even the
countries that didn't agree with him
even the Palestinians that reviled him
because he wouldn't agree with them they
respected him and and even the
Palestinians said that the only guy who
can make peace is Trump because he's
tough and he's strong and he backs up
what he says and none of us can uh can
pull the will over his eyes you know
what what we say uh on the Arab streets
in in Arabic is going to get translated
he's going to find out about it he's not
going to give us you know the wiggle
room to you know to to say nice things
in English for the American press and
then say something different to the Arab
Street you know he's holding us
accountable it's very interesting you
know know I mentioned to you just before
we started this interview statement by
Nietzsche that great manners seldom
credited with their stupidity and Trump
is from the perspective of a
psychologist a person who's low in trait
agreeableness so highly disagreeable or
at least highly impolite technically
speaking and that's not an insult or a
criticism by the way it just means that
he's not
um well it means that he's forthright
and blunt and Brash and able to say no
and that does have the consequence of
making him a divisive character on the
domestic front but
it's an open question how much that
forthright
and stubborn strength of character is
the prerequisite for the kinds of
negotiations that you're describing and
and that's really something that we
don't understand
we don't understand the full complexity
of human personality and what's
necessary in each situation and so why
do you think okay so now we know why
Trump could do it at least at a personal
level why do you think he cared and made
this a centerpiece of his policy because
he's a businessman in some real sense
and it wasn't self-evident to me and I
think to many people that foreign policy
would necessarily be an interest of
Trumps and yet he pursued this Middle
East policy assiduously and carefully
and with Melissa forethought let's say
it also very effectively so why was this
so important to him
so look it it it it wasn't
um it wasn't something he ran on he ran
almost entirely on a domestic agenda
um he has a uh he has a real interest
uh in Israel uh both because uh you know
people that he's close to have a deep
interest in in Israel whether it was
Jared or Ivanka or or me or many of his
friends that he uh you know he dealt
with over over years in the New York
real estate market
um he also I think was intrigued by The
Challenge because you know peace in the
Middle East is sort of you know
considered as likely as a uh as a solar
eclipse or maybe even less likely so
um you know the challenge I think was
something that that he saw interesting
and
um and look I don't I don't think he
spent a huge portion of his time uh on
this what he did is he he deputized
um Jared he uh and me to work the region
uh Jason Greenblatt as well when he was
working there uh we work the region we
we studied we uh we we thought more
about what to do
um uh we after that trip
um we began to uh move forward with some
some Real historic pro-israel moves
um both because we wanted to do it both
because the president had promised he
would do it because they were
extraordinarily uh important to many of
the people that voted for him and also
because it would give us a a real sense
of of how a pro-israel policy could
could be harmonized with a pro moderate
Sunni policy as well and you know it was
interesting
um uh my friend Jared
um likes to talk about you know his
conversations when he spoke to a few of
his uh Arab friends in in the region uh
about potentially moving our Embassy to
Jerusalem and they said to him Jared I'm
not going to tell you to move the
embassy or not move the embassy but what
I am going to tell you is that if you
move the embassy You'll Find Out Who
Your Friends Are
and um that that just struck me as a uh
as an extraordinary observation because
when we moved the embassy we did we
found out who our friends were
um you know the uh again the state
department
um uh the the CIA uh much to the
consternation of Mike Pompeo who was
running the CIA at the time but the CIA
analysts predicted that you know if we
move our Embassy we're going to create
uh a uh an arc of violence from Morocco
all the way to Pakistan
and um everything that we did on our own
all the conversations we had suggested
exactly the opposite but what do we know
what do I know I'm I'm a recovering
lawyer and you know Jared is a real
estate guy but everything we knew
everybody we spoke to said that's not
going to be the case yeah well it was
it's also the case that
well it's also the case that you know
you'd think if you were thinking about
this strategically beforehand in some
sense that the move of the embassy to
Jerusalem would have scuttled any
chances whatsoever that would be the
accepted dog by any ways that would have
scuttled any chances whatsoever of
moving forward with a broader peace
Accord
you know so much for expert prediction
but that's not at all what happened
no not only this is not what happened
but
um you know on in terms of the Arc of
getting from that trip that the
president took in May of 2017 to the
Abraham Accords one of the most
important steps along the way
counterintuitively was moving our
Embassy to Jerusalem why
because what the president was was
saying in moving his Embassy and moving
our Embassy to Jerusalem he was
delivering a few messages the first is
I keep my campaign promises I'm a
reliable Ally I told people I would move
the embassy to Jerusalem so did Obama so
did Clinton so did Bush I'm keeping that
promise you can trust me number two
um I'm going to fulfill the will of the
American people the American people have
uh through their Congress voted
overwhelmingly to move the embassy to
Jerusalem through the Jerusalem Embassy
act I'm taking that view seriously I
care what the American people think the
other presidents have all signed waivers
I'm going to do something different
number three I'm not afraid I'm not who
would I be afraid of in doing I'm not
afraid of Rogue Nations I'm not afraid
of the threats of of Rogue Nations I'm
not afraid of terrorism I'm not afraid
of Rogue actors I'm going to do what's
best for America I'm going to do what I
promised and um somebody wants to uh
wants to complain you know you have my
phone number but but I'm doing what uh
what I think is right right and as you
said you get to know then who supports
you and who complains in a real concrete
sense right because it's no longer
abstract it's something that actually
happened something that was in some
sense let's say provocative but also
justifiable especially from the from
from the Democratic legislative
perspectives and so you know who
complained I mean apart from apart from
some you know perfunctory uh words of
complaints that were uh that were kind
of meaningless you know who complained
Hamas you know a terrorist organization
dedicated to Israel's destruction nobody
else complained even even the pH so we
don't we don't we don't care about that
and in fact we're happy about it because
you always want to irritate the right
people in some real sense yeah but and
and and so you know we we we now uh we
now did a couple of things
we proved that we would keep promises we
proved that we would stand with our Ally
Israel and and and and and and recognize
what the American people have recognized
for two decades that Jerusalem's the
capital of Israel We're Not Afraid okay
we're and and we're willing to so so
what happened
um what happened was a lot of countries
uh took notice
and instead of being angry they said wow
you know America can really be a good
friend to its allies it could be counted
upon under this president
how do we get in on this you know how do
we join this circle of trust it seems
like you know uh you know a whole
different you know America this guy
Trump you know I want to be with him I
don't want to be against them
I see I see so okay so let me ask you
another question here that's that's a
little bit of a sideways move okay so as
I mentioned when I introduced you you
know my ignorance knows no bounds and I
want to talk a little bit about Jared
Kushner and Jason Greenblatt so I'll
tell you right off the bat that I know
very little about Jared Kushner but I
can tell you what I do know and how I
learned it and what I know is that he's
a reprehensible individual who was never
suited for his job and he was a
nepotistic appointee by the Trump
Administration and that there is nothing
good about him on any front and I
learned all of that I would say from my
casual uh interactions with the Legacy
Media whom I've learned to trust about
absolutely nothing and so what I'm
curious about is
I need to know more I would like to know
more about Jared and why you and Jason
Greenblatt and more about Greenblatt as
well why you Outsiders first of all were
brought in and why you were able to you
know what was Trump's justification for
bringing you in why did you agree to do
with this and why were you able to and
willing to move the Log Jam like in some
sense it makes sense right if
something's been stuck for 50 years
maybe you don't want to stay working
with the same people who've been stuck
for 50 years and so Outsiders
arguably at least can look at something
different the counter argument would be
well you guys were in some real sense I
don't think this is overstating it but
foreign policy and and and and and
policy amateurs and so
why you what why did this the teamwork
between the three of you work what
positive attributes I suppose had
negative attributes did you bring to
bear on the problem and why did it work
so
um you know that's probably uh that
question is probably uh requires a book
to fully answer uh and and I and I I
have you know I have some of that in in
my book but
um but I would say that first of all uh
you know starting off kind of on a macro
level I don't think you have the Abraham
Accords without Jared Kushner I think
Jared
um did two things that were essential
for the Abraham Accords the first of
which was just generally I think he
established
um really uh important relations of
trust with
um with with these countries now how do
you know that
we announced the Abraham Accords the
first one with the UAE on August 13th of
2020.
um this was we did it from the White
House we did it from the Oval Office
this was an oval office that was plagued
by leaks you know as well as me leaks
every day I mean every single day
somebody was running to the Press with
something about Trump what he was about
to do something unflattering uh or even
something good I mean but the leaks were
just rampant all right when we were
working on the Abraham Accords really
you know from the day we began we were
working on our agreement with the UAE
for over a month
um when we announced the deal with the
UAE on August 13th it really shocked the
world nobody saw it coming nobody Why
did no one see it coming because Jared
and I and and uh Jason had already left
the government at that point but Jared
and I and the president and Mike Pompeo
Robert O'Brien uh Mike Pence that was it
that was the universal people in America
who knew about this
um Israel you know probably Netanyahu
and Ron dermer and his National Security
advisor three or four people in the UAE
that the level of trust that we
established and Jared was really I would
say the key to all that that creating
that level of trust the trust was
extraordinary when they got done without
trust the second thing that Jared did
which is I think maybe even more
remarkable so we put out a we put out a
peace plan okay in January of 2020.
um most people consider it to be
extraordinarily uh pro-israel in my you
I think it was it was the most the
maximalist position that could be given
to the Palestinians uh with uh you know
in a deal that involved Israel uh it had
the support of a right-wing Israeli
government
um uh which you know the Palestinians
you know ran to the security Council and
ripped it up when we announced this deal
there were responses you know from Saudi
Arabia UAE a bunch of Morocco other
countries and Jared worked like like he
worked day and night to make sure that
even though the Palestinians were going
to trash this deal we got you know we
got more of a positive response you know
from the moderate Sunni Nations and we
did I mean we got a we got a response
from Saudi Arabia that said this is a
good start we think this should be the
basis of future negotiations under the
supervision of the United States and
that's from Saudi Saudi was the author
of the Arab peace initiative which is
which which had been their default
position for 30 years I mean it was a
one-page document that Israel could
never accept so so you know Jared was
able to to work these countries in a way
how how how how did he do it so you know
what
um I I actually think it was
um it was in the it was in the
relationship
um you know
um uh I think first of all
um he had huge credibility because you
know in the Gulf the um you know the the
almost almost always the guy who's sort
of the second in command at the gulf in
any of these Gulf countries is related
to the King right so I mean I I think
they saw Jared you know as a prince you
know this is a guy who really you know
we can trust him he can deliver for the
president the president's Never Gonna
Leave This guy hanging so he's credible
okay so he's credible variety of reasons
very very credible also look
um very very smart
um you know this unfortunately you know
doesn't come across Jared doesn't
um doesn't do much media but very very
smart he's got a book coming out in
August I can't wait to read it uh I
think oh I should interview him you
should because
um I haven't I don't know what it says
I'm really looking forward to reading it
but very very smart and with his eye on
the ball uh extremely loyal to Israel
real you know his grandparents are
Holocaust Survivors his parents are have
invested huge amounts of their
philanthropic dollars into Israel but um
but at the same time uh made many trips
to the gulf and just developed
credibility so so I I I think that's
that's really the heart of it and this
okay and so let's let's talk about this
relation issue so he was meeting people
in person I presume and and how did he
pick the people and and and and what is
it that he offered them because we also
haven't talked about the details the
specific details of the Accords
themselves which we have to get into but
I'm very interested in the process and
so okay so he was credible he was close
to Trump people assumed that he had the
power to do what he said he was going to
do
yes then I think a lot of This was
um
you know face-to-face meetings and
discussions
um you know what are you concerned about
what do you guys need what do you think
is important for uh for the relationship
with the United States I mean it's it's
really
um a lot of talking and a lot of
listening and a lot of getting to know
each other and trying to find out where
there was Common Ground now you know in
in the early uh years in 2017 and 2018
you know they were saying uh some of
these countries were saying to Jared
look Jared you know we we need to find a
way to get there it's complicated it's
difficult
um but you know let's just keep let's
just stay in touch and keep working this
relationship and find ways to uh to get
closer I mean it it wasn't like Jared
said here's what I want you here's a
piece of paper sign this here's what I
want you to do it was much more right
much more kind of touchy feely in the
first couple of years yeah yeah well
that's so important day I mean it's also
the case that it's very necessary not to
have the details of this sort of process
worked out on paper by bureaucrats who
actually have no power whatsoever to
transform it into policy but to find
decision makers who like Kushner are
close enough to actual sources of power
so that when the discussions occur the
probability that the agreement is going
to be transformed into action is
extremely high and that's a very
difficult thing to negotiate if you're
only dealing with mid to lower level
bureaucrats now I mean Jared was there
often and and you know he had three or
four you know major portfolios and this
is one of them and you know and look
Jason while Jason was um in government
would Trek over there as well uh he'd
sit and listen Jacob's Jason's a a great
listener uh he's very very
non-threatening he's uh
um you know of uh I would say I'm I'm
much pushier and more aggressive than
him so you know I'm sure that I'm sure
people were happy to to listen and host
him and he listens and he heard and he
would come back with with thoughts and
you know we look the the we were told by
everybody don't put out a plan
you know for peace between Israel and
the Palestinians because it's not going
to go anywhere and after all these
conversations we came to the conclusion
that if we can come up with a plan which
at least Israel is willing to accept
and and explain why this is reasonable
um and and if the Palestinians aren't
going to go for it and they're going to
kind of blow themselves up on the world
stage even that I think will go a long
way to convincing some of these other
countries that the that that that the
time that the time has passed the
Palestinians by it's time to move on I
mean we don't give up on making peace
with the Palestinians but if Israel is
willing to really go forward with their
with a serious plan and the Palestinians
just want to rip it up that gives
everybody a certain amount of cover to
to start doing what's best for their own
people
well yeah well you guys you guys you
guys removed the
the power they had in some sense if the
state department had assumed that peace
was only possible through the
Palestinians then that put a tremendous
amount of authority and Power in their
hands and so by walking around them in
multiple directions you eliminated that
ultimatum power in some sense that the
Palestinians had always wielded the
first thing we did I think you know your
viewers might be interested in knowing
the first thing we did is was back also
in May of 2017 you know there were a
number of people that were speaking to
the president and they were saying that
the Palestinians were ready to make
peace it's Netanyahu who's the uh who's
the uh the the difficult one uh in this
relationship uh go to Israel beat up on
Bibi and you know make him uh more
reasonable and the Palestinians will
come to the table and you'll win a Nobel
Prize and and a lot of people were
telling him that uh including people um
inside the inside government and so when
the president comes to uh to Israel uh I
went to uh I did something which I got a
lot of heat for afterwards but I went
and I told the I said to Netanyahu look
just so you know there are people the
president's being told that you're the
problem that you're the trial you're the
Troublemaker you're the guy that won't
make a deal and he said well that's not
true and I said well look uh uh if you
want to convince the president what I
would suggest you do is Let's Make a
two-minute video of some of the worst
things that uh Mahmoud Abbas has said I
mean he's supposed to be The Peacemaker
let's put together a film nothing out of
context only the other the actual
statements he's made about how you know
the blood of every terrorist is Holy and
that one will never stop uh uh helping
our our holy terrorists and we won't
give up one inch of Israel and we're
going to take all of Jerusalem and I
mean put that let the president see it
and he said to me uh David you know I've
met with you know countless world
leaders I've never made him made a video
for them I said well just make it maybe
we'll won't use it maybe we will we got
into a room and got into a room
and um and the the video was there uh I
was there with you know Tillerson and
the McMaster and Jared and and I said to
the president did you see the film and
he said what film and I said let's let's
play the film and he looked at the film
he was shocked and he said this is the
guy is this the same guy that I met with
in Washington this is the guy that
everybody's telling me is ready to make
peace and then the next day he goes to
Bethlehem to meet with Abbas and for
starters a boss doesn't let me doesn't
let me attend he banishes me from the
meeting yeah I did which which got which
got the president very angry and then
the president just really let him have
it but it also signifies an intent
doesn't it that the fact that he didn't
let you come that's that's a very
interesting and I would say
counter-strategic move on his part it
was a mistake everything indicates the
sort of person that he is yeah it was a
mistake and it got the president angry
and the president said to him look you
know you're not going to pull the will
over my eyes there's too many people
watching you right now you know you told
me you wanted to make peace I see this
video so it's exactly the opposite I
want to know who you are okay don't do
this to me it's a big mistake don't play
Both Sides I'm not stupid I can uh you
know I I form judgments very quickly you
know who are you and and and that also
really changed the Dynamics of the
relationship we'll get back to our
discussion with Ambassador Friedman in
just a moment but first I want to tell
you about Helix sleep now getting a good
night's sleep is one of the most
important things you can do for your
health that's why Helix sleep provides
tailored mattresses based on your unique
sleep preferences if you're a side
sleeper they have models with memory
foam layers for optimal pressure relief
stomach and back sleeper models have a
more responsive foam to cradle and
support your body don't forget those
enhanced cooling features to keep you
from overheating at night every Helix
mattress has a hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
it's a perfect combination of comfort
and support get started with the Helix
sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes plus right
now Helix sleep is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows at helixsleep.com Jordan that's
helixsleep.com Jordan for 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows
Helix mattress ships straight to your
door free of charge try for 100 nights
risk-free what do you have to lose go to
helixsleep.com Jordan now I want to move
in two directions one after the other
here let's talk a little bit more about
the details of the Accord so what is it
exactly that this
agreement
puts forward in principle or binds the
signatory states to UAE Bahrain Sudan
and Morocco we can talk about the
commonalities across the states and the
differences but can you can you give us
all a description of the fundamental
nature of the Abraham Accords
sure so the Abraham Accords are
structured in two parts there is the
there
there's the Abraham Accords declaration
which is the same for every country
in which there is a recognition that the
parties will end their state of conflict
and their state of hostilities they will
recognize each other's uh each other's
sovereignty they will normalize
relationships and in all different ways
whether it's cultural economic political
uh they'll engage in strategic
cooperation on matters of common
interests for their respective National
Securities they'll open up embassies
reciprocal embassies and the two and
their countries in the exchange
ambassadors so it's basically it's a
full normalization of of peaceful
relation then and now now that's the
that's the um the uh the overall if you
will Common Abraham Accords now with
each country if you look at it the way
the way I tend to look at it is each
Abraham Accord is like a triangle you
have Israel and a Muslim country at the
base and you have America at the Apex
and in each case you know something
different is happening I'll give you
some examples like with Sudan with Sudan
the um they wanted to be taken off uh
the the terrorist okay and and the
Sudanese government had done significant
things to uh to combat terrorism
um by getting them off the terror list
the the terror watch list uh the United
States was able to help them with you
know some basic humans that they needed
they needed grain they needed I mean
it's a very poor country so in in the
case of Sudan you know we we were we
helped them you know kind of end their
status as a terrorist Pariah they
deserved it and by the way it's
incredibly important for Israel because
most of the arms that were heading up
into uh into Hamas were going up through
Sudan through Sinai into into uh into
Hamas into the Gaza Strip so that's
Sudan um in the case of in the case of
Morocco Morocco had a long-standing uh
territorial dispute with a group called
The polisario in the western Sahara
um we had we had felt for years that
um Morocco um was that the world was
better off with Morocco having
sovereignty over this territory
um a lot of other countries didn't
recognize that sovereignty we recognized
Morocco's sovereignty over certain that
parts of the western Sahara that was
sort of the lubricant that got them you
know to to the table in the case of UAE
in the case of UAE they're really that
you know UA was you know is is looking
for some Advanced Weaponry we said look
we you know we don't can there is a uh
Israel is entitled entitled by law to a
qualitative military Edge you know that
assessment will be done by professionals
but but clearly to the extent that you
that there are no hostilities and you've
normalized with Israel and you know you
have diplomatic relationships that's
certainly going to going to fare well in
the calculus you know it doesn't it may
or may not be enough that's not for us
to decide but that will certainly fare
well in the calculus of your
relationship with the United States and
the United States military in the case
of Bahrain they were actually the
easiest they um
they didn't ask for there was nothing in
particular that was uh on the table but
you know they they wanted they they
thought and I think correctly so that
their people would be advantaged by by
all the
um opportunities that stem from you know
the relationship with Israel remember
that Israel has
um extraordinary
uh advancements in technology whether
it's food Tech agritech water technology
you know cyber defense Financial
technology I mean they were a world
leader I would say that in in cyber
they're they're they're they may be tied
with America you know I mean in water
technology they may be number one so I
mean there's a lot that Israel can
provide once these relationships begin
to Bloom as a trading partner right
right right yeah okay okay so great well
that all sounds extremely positive and
it's it's very interesting to see the
the commonality the Declaration of Peace
that's explicit direct Mutual
recognition of sovereignty that's a big
deal the cooperation and normalization
of political relationships including the
establishment of embassies and the
opening of doors to communication and
then the cultural cooperation which
allows for example for Israel to be
treated and to become a genuine trading
partner which you could see I mean if if
Israel is in some sense the Silicon
Valley of the Middle East which I think
is a perfectly reasonable way of looking
at it that could be of incalculable
economic value for for the for the
surrounding Arab people and so hooray
for that Jordan if you if you go to uh
Ben-Gurion airport on any particular day
today and you look at the flight board
um there there are more flights leaving
Israel for
um Abu Dhabi in Dubai then I think
almost any other location around the
world I mean it's it's really
extraordinary how this has blossomed
over the last couple of years
okay and who do you who do you think I
like to give credit where credit is due
and so we've talked a little bit about
the Americans who were signally
important in bringing this about
um
and including in the background from
what I understand Mike Pence
um so who on the side of the UAE we
meant you mentioned some of the leaders
there how about in Bahrain Sudan and
Morocco who played a signal role in
those countries
so you know I think in Morocco it was
the foreign minister who was
um at all times taking his instructions
from King Muhammad VI in UAE um they
have a a very skillful ambassador to the
United States named Yusuf alotiba who
really took the lead I think on behalf
of the UAE but of course subject to the
approval of uh Sheikh Mohammed bin Zayed
who is the who was the Crown Prince in
the ruler in in in in Sudan you know
they had they had a civilian government
and a military uh government as well
they they they they had to reconcile in
order to do this they've since split
there's since been a uh a military coup
in Sudan the United States under Biden
uh that doesn't seem to recognize
anymore the Abraham Accords with Sudan
but Israel does and frankly the the
military the the military of Sudan
continues to support the Abraham Accords
and for Israel's purposes that's that's
the most important that's enough yeah
right right
um and uh you know so I mean there's but
you know this was done uh just and I
think you you know this intuitively but
this was done at the highest levels of
government of every one of the
governments right right right all right
so let's talk about consequences so as
far as you're concerned what are the
present cons what have been the present
consequences of the Abraham Accords as
they've ruled out so far
well I think they've they've done
enormous good for uh for American
National Security for Israel's National
Security and for the National Security
of all the Sunni Nations because
um with this surfacing of diplomatic
relations has also come a good deal of
of additional cooperation with regard to
sharing of of intelligence and you know
when you look at the region and you see
Iran as really a threat to everyone
including the United States it's the
largest state sponsor of terrorism
anywhere in the world and so you know
the winners here are the moderate Sunni
Nations the loser is Iran Iran now has a
much more coordinated uh
um group of countries uh with regard to
opposing their um their malign intention
so that's that's sort of number one
number two I think look I think if we if
we were still in office I think we would
be able to scale these um relations to a
lot more countries including I think in
particular yeah well who yeah yeah well
okay who's who's next on the list well
look the you know the you know it could
be Oman it could be Indonesia but the
real the real you know big fish is Saudi
Arabia because Saudi Arabia is the right
Saudi Arabia is the leader of the Muslim
world it's the custodian yeah of the two
holiest sites in Islam and
um I think that we backslid horribly
over the last two years with Saudi
Arabia and you just saw that over the
last couple of days when uh when you saw
a very very uh unimpressive visit by um
by Biden you know he goes there and um
not only does he
um kind of fumble uh you know some
complaints about the killing of uh Jamal
khashoggi but he gets a lecture from the
Saudis in return about Abu ghraib so you
know that was that that didn't go well
and um got got no relief at all so what
should what should have happened in your
estimation so the Saudis like I'd
certainly seen the Abraham Accords as
and I've talked to some Saudi leaders as
well and my understanding is that
there's a quite a large contingent there
that would like to normalize relations
with the Western World more broadly and
to move Saudi Arabia out of its relative
isolation into something more
approximating normative relationship
with the rest of the world potentially
including Israel and you'd think that
would be a big deal you know and so what
should have happened in Saudi Arabia
well I I put out a tweet a few days ago
saying if I were Biden after I went to
Israel and met with the with the acting
prime minister yair lapid I would take
him with me on Air Force One I'd fly him
off to Saudi Arabia and I would sit with
him in MBS with Muhammad bin Salman and
I would do something big I would
announce some big trilateral agreement
that's that that that's there for the
taking if you're not how to do it and
Biden you know fumbled that you know
obviously miserably why why why why this
is obvious this is obvious right like if
I can figure this out and I don't know
anything about this
figure this out I can't understand why
Biden and his people can't figure this
out because I can't see anything that's
more important than doing this in some
real sense yep and it's like it's like
frankly it's I don't say it's low
hanging fruit but it's but it's not high
hanging fruit I mean it's right it's
hanging fruit
um look Biden
um uh you know he he boxed himself in
during the campaign saying that he would
treat the Saudis as a pariah State uh he
showed up here kind of hat in hand and
he got nothing on uh on oil anyway would
have made a difference because inflation
is at this point so rampant Beyond oil
I'm not sure what it makes a difference
but but the main thing I think is that
you know Biden is
um has been told to know in certain
terms by sort of the progressive left
you know you stay away from Saudi Arabia
you know like he he's he's politically
boxed in on Saudi Arabia which yeah well
he isn't he isn't boxed in unless he
wants to continue to count out to the
radical elements of his party and the
progressives he's not boxed in as at all
because as you pointed out earlier in
this conversation the radical types you
said 10 on each side I think it's far
smaller than that to be frank although I
think it's bigger on the left than on
the right there's a tiny proportion of
radicals that he's kowtowing to and he
doesn't need them and the fact that the
Democrats will not separate themselves
from the radicals has only ensured their
electoral defeat in the fall and
probably for the next presidential
election so like I just think that's
complete rubbish is we can't do this
because the progressives don't want us
to it's like no that's not true
practically it's not true strategically
it's definitely a mistake ethically
there's no grounds for it whatsoever
especially as you pointed out given that
this the path forward with Saudi Arabia
in relation to Israel and the rest of
the western world seems clear so it's an
abdication as far as I can see an
abdication absolute abdication of
responsibility on the part of
the Democrats let's say
so look I I agree with you and I think a
lot of this is political I mean it
starts with you know Barack Obama making
this terrible deal with Iran that has
um you know insignificant uh
verification rights and inspection
rights and expires at this point would
expire in just a few years
um when Trump got out of that deal and
and Biden comes in but so Biden
politically says I'm going to go and try
to reinstate this deal he's been chasing
the Iranians now for a year and a half
trying to get back into the jcpoa it
makes no sense but he's doing it because
you know that's the deal that he and
Obama you know came up with and they
want to validate that they want to they
want somehow to resuscitate that the
more Biden chases the jcpoa which he'll
fail at anyway I mean it's there's
nothing to be achieved there but the
more he chases that and Chase is this
you know this fantasy of diplomacy with
the Iranians he pushes the Saudis
further away he pushes the Israelis
further pushes everybody further away
and so it's the it's this it's this kind
of you know misguided
um uh chasing after the fantasy of a
diplomatic outcome with Iran that
precludes Saudi Arabia and how much how
how much do you think this reflexive
identification with the Palestinians as
victims is driving the necessity of
turning to the Iranians instead of the
Saudis or is that a separate issue well
it may be a separate issue but it's the
same people it's exactly the same people
yeah who hold both views
right well that's why I'm curious about
the the connection yeah
yeah look the the it was I have to tell
you uh this was the last few days have
been a frustrating experience for me
because what I saw over the last few
days was a complete reversal of all the
things that we did that made the Middle
East a much more safe and stable place
you know all the things that we did were
kind of reversed in just a few days
throwing money at the Palestinians not
demanding any accountability refusing to
recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
all of Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel then running to Saudi Arabia you
know uh and um you know you know
resuscitating complaints that just
resulted you know the Saudis aren't dumb
they have answers for this you know I
mean so they they they go back and now
Biden's on his heels trying to defend
Abu ghraib because because he brought up
uh khashoggi
um and and from there just went nowhere
he went home he went home you know with
his happiness in nothing he got nothing
out of it and you know uh we could have
gotten so much more on this trip it was
I don't even know why they had the trip
I mean why why would you orchestrate a
trip like this if you're just gonna
insult your allies and come home
empty-handed well my my prime minister
my prime minister Justin Trudeau tends
to orchestrate a trip like that when the
scandals and inflation on the domestic
front get so unbearable that he needs to
distract people yep yep well that's
sounds like that's exactly what happened
here okay so let's talk about an
elephant under the carpet here so you
talked a lot about making peace with the
the Sunny the Sunni moderates where are
the moderate Shiites in all of this and
what is the fact that they're not at the
table like what lurking catastrophes are
associated with that and how might that
be rectified
well look the the the uh the Shiites
that um that are relevant here are you
know kind of half of Iraq or slightly
more than half of Iraq
um Hezbollah in uh in Lebanon
and in Iran and um in all three cases
but especially in Iran but I mean true
of Hezbollah as well they're not
moderate uh there there's nothing
there's not the slightest thing moderate
about them and
um and they you know they are at this
point you know look are there are there
uh radical sunnis of course you have
Isis you have uh Hamas is uh is is a
Sunni although they're being funded by
Iran but um you know the the primary and
I'm not suggesting that there aren't
moderate Shiites I'm sure there are but
but the ones that that make noise are
primarily you know in Iran and in
Hezbollah and they're the farthest thing
from moderate I mean they represent
existential threats to the state of
Israel and elsewhere so why did you guys
have no luck with them and what do you
think might be done uh by someone who
was competent if they were inclined to
uh redress that that block I I I don't
think there is
um I I don't think there's anything
that can be done with either Iran or
Hezbollah except from a position of real
strength and and Hezbollah really is is
just a uh it's it's a proxy for the
Iranians as are the houthis in Yemen and
and they're very and they're very
dangerous and
um and they don't accept any kind look
I'll give you an example which is kind
of uh heartbreaking lebanon's a very
poor country
um they have off they have a significant
offshore uh gas deposit that could be
commercialized very much for the benefit
of the people in Lebanon
um there's a question of who owns it I
mean it's kind of right on the seam of
uh Israel's territorial Waters and the
lebanon's territory Awards Israel is
willing to make a deal
to to solve that Maritime dispute where
you know they'll get some of the gas and
and Lebanon get some of their guests
Lebanon we get a lot of gas it would
make a big deal for their economy
hospital I won't let them make the deal
yeah that that's it what about what
about behind the scenes negotiations
like if the if the political leaders in
the Shiite Community can't pull this off
then is there another level of of people
in Shiite culture or in other countries
as you reached out to the UAE and Sudan
and Morocco Etc could you could you walk
around Iran
um in the same way
no no unfortunately not I mean I'm sure
again I'm I'm sure there are uh people
of the Shiite Faith who are reasonable
but the um but but the but those the the
Shia who control Weaponry are you know
in Iran and in Lebanon and in in Syria
and in uh and in Iraq and in parts of
Yemen and they're all they're all you
know um militant terrorists they all
take their instructions from Iran and
and and there's there really isn't an
opportunity there the the opportunity is
for the uh the moderate Muslim world to
unite with America and with Israel and
this threat can be defeated I have no
doubt this threat can be uh can be
defeated but but I don't think right now
it can be solved except through uh the
strongest of uh positions taken by our
allies okay okay so let's let's close
this up maybe if uh with two with with
with the discussion about the response
in the west I was a late learner about
the Abraham Accords um I mean the
world's been pretty weird in the last
couple of years and I was also very ill
and I sort of emerged from that and was
informed about the Abraham Accords by
some people on the ambassadorial front
and became extremely interested in them
for three reasons first of all because
well look peace is breaking out in the
Middle East and so that was one and
isn't that surprising and then also
um curious because
given that this is as far as I can tell
a truly historic Accord
I would have hoped that it would have
been like front page two inch type news
on the New York Times for example and
that everybody everywhere would know
about all its details and then
furthermore that the people who
structured it were not only nominated
for the Nobel Prize which is not that
difficult to process to be nominated but
actually to be nominated but actually
awarded it since this actually
constituted peace and I couldn't help in
my cynical uh what would you say musings
contrast that with the willingness of
the Nobel committee to give a Peace
Prize to Barack Obama before President
Obama even had a chance to demonstrate
whether or not he was a peacemaker on
the international scene and so why what
in your estimation has been the response
in the west among intellectuals and the
press and then among well let's say the
American people and people in the west
more broadly
well look the the the the the attention
from the Press has been uh disappointing
um we had a ceremony on September 15th
on the south lawn of the white house
that day
uh the picture of trump and Netanyahu
and the leaders of Bahrain and UAE it
made the front page of all the major
papers uh so we got we got one good day
out of it but the way it's been uh
expanded and the way it's flourished the
the effect it's had on the people of
Israel the people of UAE uh the the
optimism and opportunity uh is brought
to the Middle East uh none of that has
been has been covered uh at all and I
think it's all because of uh because it
came from from from us from the Trump
Administration yeah but that's that's no
bloody excuse here that's no excuse like
this isn't this transcends the political
as far as I'm concerned and I think as
far as anybody reasonable would be
concerned and it's important to give the
devil his due and that's the case even
if the devil happens to be Trump and his
damned minions and the facts seem to me
to be clear on the ground that this
represents a significant and very
unexpected move forward on the Peace
front in the Middle East and that's been
a problem that has threatened all of us
for
for 70 years for longer than that on all
sorts of fronts and so the fact that
people don't want to give Trump credit
for this because he's Trump that is
still utterly inexcusable I I don't I
really don't understand it because it
means in some real sense that the narrow
political enmity that was directed
towards Trump For Better or For Worse
for warranted or unwarranted I don't
really care that's not the issue the
issue is that under Trump this extremely
significant event occurred I think it's
significant in the same way that the
fact that Trump didn't entangle the
United States in any stupid Wars for
four years was significant and also
extremely underplayed I mean at least he
managed that and that's not nothing but
then to also cap his four years which
were definitely conducted under extreme
duress and and intense corrosive
cynicism again regardless of his flaws
to cap that with the Abraham and then to
be ignored by intellectuals in the west
denigrated and at minimum damned with
faint praise and then also to be ignored
by the Nobel Prize committee that's not
just politics that's a kind of willfully
blind corruption that's
unforgivable in its depth
um you won't you won't get an argument
out of me
you know I've uh we well am I
overstating it I mean are there reasons
are there reasons that you and I aren't
delving into why this hasn't been more
hasn't been more celebrated like because
I don't want to devolve into the
narrowly political here you know I'm
really trying to understand this and the
Abraham Accords they're enough to bring
a tear to your eye if you have any
bloody sense
well look if you um let's just be clear
I mean this this was not a question of
uh of neglect this was an affirmative
decision by the media and by the
Democratic party to to minimize the the
benefits and the impact of the Abraham
Accords remember you know early on uh
the first year of the Biden
Administration
um they're you know the state department
spokesman was asked about the um Abraham
Accords and um and he would say yes you
know these are uh uh you know these are
normalization agreements where where um
you know we're gonna work on you know
advancing normalization agreements And
the reporter would say why don't you
just say the Abraham Accords I mean why
don't you use that phrase and he said
well what do you mean I mean I'm
referring to them as normalization
agreements that's what they were I mean
they played this silly game of cat and
mouse they wouldn't even use the words
Abraham Accords because frankly it's a
very powerful brand for these uh for
these agreements yeah but that's for
sure yeah it's a great phrase it's great
it's a great title who came up with that
by the way
uh so that's that's a great story so you
know we were about to go live just on
August 13th again there's there's
there's five or six of us to know about
this we're about to go live with a
telephone call between Trump uh and the
head of UAE and the head of Israel and
um it's like 10 minutes before we go
live and the guy comes running in he's a
he's a general Miguel Correa who's uh
who work with us on this he's a two star
general he came running in and said we
need a we need a name and I said why do
you need a name and he said well you
know these agreements all have names
Oslo Accords cam David Accords and I
said to him do you have any ideas he
said how about the Abraham Accords you
know Abraham was the father of the
Jewish faith the Muslim faith Christian
faith I said wow that's terrific so we
we quickly called up uh the Israelis and
the emiratis and they signed off on it
and that's how that's how we got got the
name
yeah well getting the name right is
really important and so that was a very
wise move on on his part yes so so I
should mention too to everyone that you
wrote a book about this
um Sledgehammer what's the full what's
the full name of the book Sledgehammer
how breaking with the past brought peace
to the Middle East
and when was that published it came out
a little over five months ago on
February 8th of uh of this year
um it had the biggest
um week of any book on Israel in the
last 10 years is what the what the
Publishers report it was uh it's thank
God been a very successful book
well that's good have have any of the
Intelligentsia so to speak which is a
hated name as far as I'm concerned at
the moment has has anybody reviewed it
seriously and and how has it been
received it's been received well it
didn't get
um you know I it wasn't reviewed by you
know the New York Times or uh or some of
those yes well why would it be all right
it's just about it's just about peace in
the Middle East you know why would you
review a book about that by one of the
authors of the Accord it was also you
know a book I think about
um about the kind of the the the inner
fortitude it took to fight the
conventional wisdom the the headwinds if
you will of the state department and the
defense department and how and how
important it was that I had the support
of the president because you know
whether it was moving the embassy or
recognizing uh sovereignty over the
Golan Heights or the peace plan or or
changing our view on the legality of
settlements in the West Bank I mean we
did all these different things and every
one of them was opposed by numerous
government agencies so it really was
about
um The Runaway the support the
confidence I was thinking by the
president because at the end of the day
if you have the president's support you
don't need the support of any of these
agencies it's only when the president
you know right you know it goes on to
some other thing which he consider is
more important that you're stuck in the
morass of the agency well the president
gave me huge amounts of authority and
Runway and that I think was the key to a
lot of the success so right so he gave
you some autonomy and some trust and so
well kudos to you Jared Kushner and
Jason Greenblatt anybody else you want
to include in that inner circle on the
American side who is key to the success
of this you did mention Mike Pence
anybody else you thought was I know
there's a huge team but well it wasn't
actually wasn't the huge team I mean
Mike Pompeo was uh was essential because
at the end of the day you know
um you know Jared and I uh you know we
have a relationship with the president
we have authority but we're not the
Secretary of State we're not we're not
we're not in charge of the U.S farm our
policy so we needed Mike to really jump
in and engage and provide the types of
assurances that as much as we were
trusted I mean the right messaging
needed to come from the state department
we had a young guy Avi Berkowitz who
worked for Jared who was on the phone
day and night you know working the lower
level relationships and uh and was very
helpful and
um and that's about it I mean that's
about it it was a relatively small group
of people that worked you know really
day and night especially towards the end
of the Trump Administration to getting
this done well thank you thank you to
all of them that's for sure from
everybody in the world who has any sense
I would say so let me just summarize
what we discussed and then maybe you can
add a few additional comments if you'd
like
the Accords
um involve at minimum Declaration of
mutual peace recognition of mutual
sovereignty uh the establishment of a
framework of cooperation and principle
and reality including the exchange and
establishment of ambassy embassies and
also cultural cooperation that could
bring the benefits of mutual trade to
those countries uh it's a major
accomplishment it looks expandable
perhaps to countries like Oman Indonesia
and Saudi Arabia especially on the Sunni
side
um and it's an amazing achievement and I
would like to shame the Nobel Prize
committee for making a tremendous error
in failing to note with the prize that
should have been awarded for what
appears to me
um uh a signal
a signal accomplishment of the first
part of this new millennium you know my
my job was very much on the U.S Israel
side of the relationship
um I think we proved something which
um I I fear that the uh you know kind of
the left-wing Elites are sliding back on
but what I what we proved and I said it
at the beginning and president Trump
said it at the beginning is that Israel
really is a solution in the Middle East
not a problem and you know for 70 years
the state department viewed Israel as a
problem to be managed not as an
opportunity to be harnessed and and I
think we're sliding back in that
direction right now you know with with
the last few months of of U.S policy but
um you know we when we we Advanced all
these extraordinary initiatives on
behalf of our Ally our cherished Ally
the state of Israel not only did they
not bring violence but they brought
peace and I think that message is one
that we can scale and extend populate
going forward and I really hope we do
well let's say Amen to that and all pray
that this does move forward as it should
and that wise heads prevail outside of
the domain of narrow politicking and and
partisan advantage
so I'm going to follow up this
conversation for those of you who are
listening I do a behind the scenes
30-minute interview with everybody I
talk to now on on The Daily wire plus
platform and I'm going to talk to
Ambassador Friedman in a more personal
sense I would say and and detail out the
development of his career across the
span of his life insofar as we can
manage that in 30 minutes I like to give
people some insight into how people who
have done who have accomplished signal
achievements have come to that position
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com